[Applause]
[Music]
it's a new releases special delivery
typically on this show we run down some
of the hottest games coming to all
platforms each week but right now we've
got a new special sponsored episode
thanks to PlayStation Store is totally a
digital sale these games are digital
exclusives find them at PlayStation
Store over the next few weeks let's jump
right into the new batch of games laser
League calls itself a future sport and
with all the crazy neon lights and
lasers flashing on the court it's not
wrong the goal is simple take control of
the light nodes by turning them your
team's color but of course it gets
deeper from there your opponent's color
will totally fry you not only that but
each of the six classes has their own
strengths weaknesses and perks and did I
mention there are power-ups to laser
League looks to be a great example of
that easy to learn difficult to master
mentality of other big-name sports you
can find out for yourself by joining a
team and jumping into the competition on
Thursday May 10th speaking of sports
let's talk about basketball NBA
playgrounds - continues the over-the-top
style of the first game with more
two-on-two matches with a bunch of new
modes for playing solo or online the
biggest addition is the playgrounds
championship mode which will let you
climb the ladder with other players all
across the globe and of course there's a
season mode for taking a team to the top
by yourself with over 200 players from
NBA history to choose from you have tons
of options for putting together the best
all-star duo with more unlocked through
virtual card packs you can take a shot
on May 22nd if you'd rather be
competitive in a battle royale game then
let me introduce you to h1z1 the
free-to-play game is coming to ps4 with
some changes that will make the whole
game move faster and it's more than just
having the controls converted over to a
DualShock controller for one you won't
waste time crafting here top level gear
like weapons and armor can instead be
found in supply drops the gas zone also
shrinks faster squeezing all players
into closer quarters pretty quickly if
you think you've got what it takes to
survive you can jump into h1z1 when the
open beta kicks off on May 20
and those are some of the hottest
totally digital games will be playing
over the next few weeks let us know in
the comments if you decide to grab any
of these from PlayStation Store regular
episodes of new releases go live every
Sunday so stay tuned for more great
games you'll want to pick up thanks for
watching
[Music]